this is Jocko podcast number 128 with
echo Charles and me Jacque are willing
good evening echo good evening it's been
a little bit since we've done the QA so
we're gonna roll into some QA and gonna
try and answer more questions than
normal with some shorter answers got a
lot of Twitter questions which
necessitates shorter questions and
thereby in some cases shorter answers
I've got a I've got some more detailed
answers or detailed questions stacked up
for another QA but for today we're just
gonna try and get through some of these
we're no guarantee on that button what's
rockin off cool taco do you believe in
overtraining do you believe in
overtraining
or is that an excuse people use you have
the CT Fletcher's triathletes yourself
etc who get after daily you also find
other elite athletes who believe in rest
days who are by no means slackers what's
your take you know what can you ever
train
yes you can you know you can definitely
over train I will say this most people
don't overtrain
because you got to work pretty hard to
over train yeah and if you over train
you'll know it if you're paying
attention to your performance cuz your
performance will start to go down that
that's what's happening you know I've
said this before I've seen it with
fighters that were preparing for a fight
and they be overtraining and you'd watch
their performance someone that's
normally crushing let's say the fighters
normally crushing training partner a and
all of a sudden training a partner a
starts getting the better of the fighter
and you know you know it's it's obvious
the guys over trained so take a couple
days off get some steak and get back giv
get reset because you're over trained so
yeah you can over trained for sure
now what I don't believe in well it's
hard to over trying I mean these guys
are working hard when they're over
training but a lot of people just they
they do you can use overtraining as an
excuse yeah what I do is I'm gonna do
something every day I try and do
something every day regardless like even
if even if I feel like I'm completely
last night I got kind of beat up on the
map I know I'm pretty I'm pretty
overtrained right now but I'm also
getting ready to go on the trip so I'm
like okay well I just gonna still school
I squatted today and I'm still gonna
train hard tonight and then I got a
couple days where I'll be on the road I
might take one of those days and just
like do more of a stretch mobility so I
scenario work I'll still get the blood
flowing because I got to get the blood
flowing God but you know maybe just like
a hundred burpees and then a bunch of
stretching so I'll do a little recovery
on the road but yes you can over train
it's hard to do it if your performance
is going down you're overtraining
the eat some steak take a break take a
break eat some steak
well hundred burpees come a lot I think
hundred burpees yeah you know it's like
that's less than ten minutes put it this
way I did oh then again all the times I
did 100 burpees was after yeah out so
this feels a little different yeah yes
go do 100 burpees yeah that well the key
okay so overtraining though is like
there's two or maybe even more different
kinds of overtraining so there's like
there's like a for-real like I don't
know from I'm gonna miss using a
clinical version of overtraining which
is like official like your blood you can
recognize it in your blood and like
certain things and certain whatever and
there's all just they're not a spot it's
a thing that's the actual thing like you
don't sleep and it's like your body B
essentially goes into this like- kind of
feedback or positive feedback loop or
it's like but just your overtraining and
it takes like a while to get out of it
like a while you got to go through this
process and then there's also like a
condition like rhabdo so yeah right oh
that's a serious situation yeah that's
essentially overtraining
yes that's acute you're training quickly
yeah usually to get hit with the rabble
yeah and then there's like this kind of
gray area and you can get rhabdo
I guess you can i think i think you get
rhabdo in like certain muscle groups
confer but anyways rhabdo yeah that'll
take you out
I remember cake nuts was we were rolling
cake that's he's the kind guy who's like
just kind of down for anything not this
kind of likes fireplug type guy because
he's super mellow but he's just down for
any
like the kind where if you're gonna go
do something kind of weird heal or
whatever he'll always sort of just be
there you know he always kind of says
yes so anyway we're training and he you
know when someone asks you to roll and
you're done you're like oh I'm not done
maybe next time you know not cake nuts
no he was like okay does and you can
tell you like tired it's like okay and
then we're all done already and then you
know how certain guys come in late or
whatever maybe one two guys and another
guy asked him the wrong like dang cake
that's still rolling and I think even
rolled before us too and he was just
rolling rolling he mighta did some other
PT or whatever
it is like madam I'm pretty tired right
now and then another guy asks oh well
let's roll and he's like okay and we're
just laughing like it's a white belt
yeah it means all these which means all
these rolls are not like yeah relaxed
scenarios their actual level 9 death
battles yeah he's going for it yeah he's
a pretty girl by the way
oh that's cool yeah but yeah at the time
I think he was a white belt and yeah so
he goes to me like man I'm tired I'm
messed up and I was like yeah man I dig
it you rolled a lot and sure and come to
find out he had wrapped oh yeah but
anyway go and then there's a great area
over training where you're training a
lot maybe your testosterone will be down
from training a lot and me you know your
nutrition may or may not be all that
kind of thing so your performance does
go down you feel a little bit more tired
going into training you know if you're
lifting or whatever you can't lift this
heavy and all this stuff that's like a
grater you're not over trained though
you just how you say just you just ache
and a day two days later boom you're
kind of back in the game you know kind
of thing but I don't think that's a
clinical technically overtrained maybe
you're not recovering day to day as much
or something like this but growing the
less but all true things all real things
hey your body is this machine man if you
you know with all these different
systems that the system's ain't work all
ain't working right you may not get you
know the performance that you are what
you want next question what would you
pack for lunch if you had a typical
nine-to-five job yeah chicken steak beef
jerky nuts I don't know a salad no no
big shocker there Yeah right
just don't eat the doughnuts in the
office next question no tuna sandwich
no tuna sandwich holy Fred tomato
lettuce sprouts that's your go-to no
that's what my mom would probably pack
for me if she was packing my lunch but
people are asking what your mom when you
were young that's good
bag of potato chips yeah well that was
PB&J good but but potato chips are not I
just manage is the same it tastes good
actually but peanut butter is good and
of course what I would do is take the
potatoes put them on the yeah like this
like all good
oh yeah so there you go you guys know
what to eat come on
but here I'm sure they're asking because
that is kind of a thing like you have a
nine-to-five job right and especially if
kind of the culture is like okay I go to
work and then boom we got well data
lunch me and my boys from work with your
lunch maybe a bar maybe you know kind of
thing but they want to break the cycle
so it's like you know it's not it's kind
of common knowledge okay break the cycle
bring your own lunch you you will
definitely bring you much not only will
you eat better but you also won't spend
$19 for lunch yeah you'll spend like $6
for lunch and it'll be better for you so
that's just yeah yeah okay so maybe I
should have made that more clear don't
go out to the little corner store and or
whatever the corner restaurant and spend
$28 for crappy food that's gonna make
you fat and lazy
yeah just pack your own food that cost
$6 that's gonna make you lean strong and
smarter yeah but and then there in comes
this question I think I don't know but I
think so because let's say you've never
done that before so great chain right
you always eat tough and I don't think
he ever like cooks at home or whatever
right and me I'm kind of well I'd kind
of do both whatever but I cook at home I
go make my go-to little things right and
hope so we're talking and I was
explained to him oh yeah oh yeah I'll
just do this when I'm on the program
I'll do this I'll make this and he's
like paying you you actually do that
unlike cook and make stuff at all
surprised yeah like he was like this
foreign thing for it okay I'll give you
a go
- right now you're on top co2 so you
said tuna I have tin chicken like I
don't even know when my wife calls it
Tintin it comes getting in yeah because
I don't really like fish
sure and so I have chicken in a can open
it up put some mayonnaise in there your
your good food yeah do that and you can
get big big Kansas oh yeah they're
Costco yeah that's a total go to yeah
yeah that's a good one lot of sodium a
lot of times and those ones you know if
you care about those kind of things but
yeah there's a lot of chicken in there
too you can do with that too if you have
just a little bit more time the ticket
the one in the cancer suite is good
because it's so fast boom over one speed
but if you uh you can like kind of
halfway boil some chicken chop it up
what is sautee it right with something
stuffing right and then chop it up even
more boom add the mayonnaise it's kind
of the same deal and you can do it that
way you don't need like they can chicken
some people do not prefer can't chicken
them that's cool that's they can do
other things yeah yeah yeah then that's
the other thing I'm talking about anyway
so well it you know there's my mom made
chicken I you know no you know how Greg
it was foreign to Greg to actually cook
at home it's foreign for people to
actually make a lunch so that like men
where do I start with this thing what do
I do
and then usually in fact from what I
understand anyway usually it's kind of
like oh all all kind of sort of by a
lunch while I'm not at work
you know maybe good as to buy one of
these box lunches or something and then
bring it in but I'm afraid it's
defeating the property that's a thing
but it's a defeating the purpose you
make the lunch like a sandwich or
something like that yeah I'm telling you
cool it works that's the direction you
want to go that's my opinion
next question you've mentioned being
involved in real estate are you still
involved how'd you get started whether
flipping or renting flipping mean buying
fixing up your selling houses or renting
or whatever did you start with a lot of
money or no is it something you are or
were very hands-on with or contract work
out I've been real lucky with
the whole real estate thing part of us
because I was in the military and while
the crash happened I did I'd even barely
knew there was an economic crash going
on and so was so we're talking 2007-2008
timeframe when the market crashed and I
was in the military so I just was
captain doing what I was doing and
bought some houses then and I would say
yeah and then I've continued to do that
so it's a good it's a good investment
long term short term you can get screwed
if you think you're gonna buy something
right now like for instance flipping a
house that's cool you can make a lot of
money but also you could buy right now
buy a house for $200,000 and think
you're gonna fix it up and sell it for
$300,000 and then you buy it and the
market crashes and now your house that
you bought for $200,000 is only worth
150 so now you're you're out of luck so
you the way I look at it you know just
as as a normal person
yeah just try and buy a house that's
number one buying my house to live in
and then try and pay it off as fast as
you can and then when you get it to a
good point and you fix it up and you
think you can rent it out that's cool
dude it rent it out and buy another one
and keep doing that one thing one you
know I'm no real estate expert I'm not
running around but you know explain I'm
not gonna put out a and we're I'm not
gonna put out a seven or real estate
investing buddy hey if you're gonna buy
a buy a house this is what this is
something a little bit of advice if
you're gonna buy a house buy a house in
the place where you want to live where
you want to live in it by the worst
crappiest house but where you want it
because the location you cannot change
once you buy it you're stuck in that
location and so it's turnkey but you can
always rebuild it and fix it up and make
it nice so buy a house I made that
mistake one time I bought a house about
a bigger house in a place where I didn't
really like it but I thought well the
house is so nice and big and about it
was like two weeks after I bought it
this is actually the first house I ever
bought two weeks after I bought it I was
saying man I should have bought the
other house I was looking at that was in
the location I wanted then it was a
little bit smaller and not as nice so
anyways buy it where you want it and
and fix it up as you go along as far as
the work doing the work all the work
that I did on my houses I did myself and
now I don't do it as much anymore cuz I
don't have time but when I was in the
Navy well you either have time where you
have money right so when I was in the
Navy I had more time if you can believe
that when I was in the Navy
and I had no money so like all my houses
when I bought him I couldn't afford them
I could barely afford them well yeah so
you gotta be that's now not advising
that because if you got to be able to
suck it up if things go sideways you're
gonna be living on no money living lis
gonna be lean Christmas that's what my
parents used to say to me and that's
what I said to my kids it's gonna be a
lean Christmas so you got to be ready
for the link grit some people aren't
ready for a lean Christmas yes some
people cannot live some people cannot
control their expenses if things go bad
mm-hmm and you know when I bought all my
just about every house I bought when I
got into my house it was like okay we
made it now we're gonna starve for two
years or whatever trying to get
everything squared away again so anyways
you got to be smart but it definitely
makes more sense to buy I shouldn't say
this because there's some people that
argue against it I think if you're gonna
live somewhere for a while
buy a house instead of paying someone
else's mortgage to pay your own and try
and pay it down as quick as you can
that's it yeah my advice cool I guess
yeah like like here's an idea when you
join the military I save up all your
money don't spend it on booze which
you're going to you're gonna want to
know because everyone's gonna be going
out don't do that
buy it buy whatever you can buy buy a
little condo buy something and then rent
out the rooms that are in it and you
sleep on the couch and you rent out the
rooms and you're paying the mortgage as
soon as you get that thing kind of
stable boom go and buy another one yeah
and that's that's how you you can start
doing it you said that it was easier for
you in the milk because you were in the
military why why is it because my
paycheck was coming no matter what well
he doesn't like I was gonna get laid off
I mean so many people got laid off
during the during the
economic downturn right right yeah they
couldn't buy it they couldn't afford
their mortgage payments anymore or not
that was made the bad situation even
worse yeah so for me it was like I was
just sitting there collecting my
paycheck as normal didn't even really
realize that the market was getting
destroyed on all fronts yeah because I
was in the military yeah and I wasn't
sitting around staring at the at the
stock market every day trying to figure
out where I was gonna go when do you get
I mean you do right you get like
benefits or it loans easier whatever
yeah there's something already a loan
yeah the which which is a good loan it's
a good loan and you can only get one
though so I mean I use that you can
reset it and you use it on other houses
but I've done a couple times but that's
a cool link little jumping-off point
it's a really good jumping-off point
yeah it's a really good jumping-off
point for sure but the thing to be
careful of is is speculating in thinking
that the prices of houses is always
gonna go up which is what everyone
fought in 2006 2007 2008 hey don't worry
the prices are just gonna keep going up
they're not they're gonna come down
sometimes yeah and so you can't Bank on
that you can't Bank on that what you
bank on is like okay I like this house
it's in a good location I'm gonna live
here for a long time if I get stuck in
it for a long time
I don't mad my mind I won't be mad and I
can suffer okay I can make my family
suffer okay like you know when you can't
take your your family out for dinner for
months on end like oh no sorry we're not
going out for dinner oh no we're not
doing that we're not buying that buying
your kids used stuff for Christmas which
I did when I was in the military okay
you know I'd love to get you something
new but guess what sometimes Santa Claus
brings some yeah recycle some recycled
good mother kids didn't want it that's
fine if you if you don't have that in
you to suck it up and and live lean then
you you don't then you need to make
different decisions yeah because a lot
of times I know it was it was like this
and like Oh 7:06 maybe we're guys like I
remember seeing people they'd like a lot
of people were just becoming loan
officers oh yeah for sure
like flipping houses you know kind of
thing and
kind of all they look at it as like this
get-rich-quick kind of thing and then
they're like yeah let me just do a few
you know experience necessary all this
stuff and then I'll do it all uneducated
I'm all like with none of what you just
said none of that and well I got a buddy
that he he was telling me the story cuz
he was in the SEAL Teams and during that
market boom during the housing market
boom
he bought like five houses yeah and he's
so funny to hear he's a humble guy and
he's Tom telling me the story is ten
years ago he told me the story but he's
like he's like yeah when I was doing
this I thought everyone else was so
stupid I was just the smartest guy in
the world because what he was doing was
getting these loans that he couldn't
afford but at that time the the mortgage
people were giving loans to anybody yeah
and he did it and he did it over and
over until he ended up with five houses
and he said he remembered asking another
real estate guy like hey what if what if
the housing prices go down and you know
the guys like that's not gonna happen
and if it does even if it did happen
you'd have six months to a year to
offload all your properties and it'd be
is no problem within a month of that the
market turned and he said thirty days
later every one of his properties was
upside down meaning he owed more than
they were worth in 30 days and he ended
up foreclosing on all those houses
except for one he was lucky enough to
keep the one that he lived in anyway so
yeah don't you know be measured its
balance don't just get crazy yeah yeah
it's not like this get rich like the
risks I would take was the risk of okay
if things don't go well it's gonna be a
lean Christmas and I'm okay with that if
you're not okay with a lean Christmas
and a lien and not going out for dinner
and buying your kids used presents for
Christmas if you're not okay with that
but you know what do you want for your
birthday oh you wanna you want something
for your birthday cool
we I'll get you something that resembles
that but it might not be the if you're
not okay with that then then don't do it
I never would gamble the fact that okay
if this goes wrong we won't have
anywhere to live that's a different
that's a different level gambling I
didn't gamble that I think gamble like
okay if I if the market goes sideways
not gonna have a place to live I didn't
gamble that if the market goes sideways
hey it's gonna be a lean Christmas yeah
yeah and even you like by your own
admission you said I you know I'd do it
where I'd live lean kind of thing like
you don't have to do it that way like
you can be set way more yeah yeah you
know you could get yourself a tea yeah
but no risk no reward
but don't risk everything
be smart be calculated yeah so yeah buy
something buy something you're young
hang on to it rent it out buy something
else
hang on to it rent it out that's a good
plan it's a good long-term plan yeah
Chuck a long-term plan long-term cuz the
market goes up and down yeah that's
probably good advice most of the time
anyway long-term yeah think long term
long term
sit down time do you ever watch mindless
- I asked you this question before do
you ever watch mindless TV or YouTube
videos to decompress at the end of the
day or is that laziness justifying
wasted time yeah you know quite frankly
I don't have a lot of free time to do
that even if I was all fired up to watch
a mindless video on YouTube yeah so I
guess I guess not really if I'm gonna
decompress sometimes I mean sometimes my
kids don't want to watch something and
I'll sit there and watch all in watch an
episode of The Office funny yeah yeah
that's a that makes sense
same same deal I think probably sir you
know of course I watched my whole life
I've oh that's a good one
kind of mindless like I didn't tell you
this I've watched zero I would if they
put it on screen right now I wouldn't
even know what it was
lay from we went we were in the hotel
gym the other day ladies like check it
out points the TV I'm like what that's
why I even know what he's talking about
yeah yeah the picture yeah he took a
picture of it he said he felt your
presence yeah it's good so it fired me
up best workout in the world right there
well if I don't work out bull shark
next question I'm a high school football
coach when you were in charge of
training at what point did you use mass
punishment yeah
mass punishment that's basically when
the teams not working together GUCH
right when the team's not working
together and that can take all kinds of
forms right but if they're if they're
not working together they're gonna get
punished together if they're blaming
each other they're getting punished
together if they're not supporting each
other's beginning get punished together
one thing that I think we're the gray
areas is if you have an individual
that's making mistakes having problems
not performing correctly and then the
team whose responsibility is it to get
that person up to speed it's the team's
responsibility so if that person
continually has a problem it's like hey
if the team doesn't take care of that
problem
then the team has to has to pay yeah
sure that makes sense man next question
instilling and maintaining discipline in
subjective career fields such as
becoming a musician artist etc how do
you face the obstacles thrown at you
when you're subjected to people's
opinions to make a living and not the
standard do your job type type of
lifestyles this this this question I'm
not sure if I have an answer that people
are gonna want to hear on this one I
think first of all I originally thought
like okay this is about discipline and
you need discipline to get good at craft
because that's for sure right if you
want to get good at music or or or
whatever you gotta you gotta have the
discipline practice it but that's not
really what the questions about the
questions about how do you survive and
how do you deal with it when people are
might not like what you make and from my
perspective I think you should do things
like art and music because you really
love doing them and not to make money
and I think I think if you do those
things truthfully from the heart then it
will strike a chord with other people in
many many cases because human beings
have whatever human nature is all kind
of
the same and so if you do something then
people will like it and then you will
end up with people that like your work
if if you're doing art or music or
whatever to make money if that's your
goal well then it's going to be
subjective and that's gonna be
problematic because people might might
not like what you're doing it so then
what you do you change it a little bit
then you change it a little bit and you
change a little bit so I don't know to
me it's like I would rather have another
job that makes me money so I can get by
so that I can do what I want
artistically mmm if that makes sense I
actually had a guy the other day that
was like saying you get up early but
different people that are artistic they
have to have a different path yeah
because they you know if someone's gonna
gonna make music or they're gonna
they're gonna draw or paint or they're
gonna write they need to have freedom
yeah I was like whoa I'm kind of written
some books and and I play music in a
band and we make rock and roll you know
what I mean
yes I didn't get all crazy with the guy
who's gonna be like no I'm an artist too
I just was like hey man you know if you
wanna you do what you want man yeah I'm
not here to help you out but that's kind
of like that like back to in the podcast
like the podcast isn't like oh well we
need to do this so that we can get more
people to listen so that we can get more
money it's no actually if you don't want
to listen this don't listen and we don't
we're beholden to no one
mm-hmm no advertisers gonna pull their
advertising from us because we don't
have any you yes so we can do what we
want yeah and not be worried about what
other people think and I think when you
do that here's the here's the here's the
the where the thread ties back in I
think if you're doing what you want and
you're creating what you want from the
heart truthfully when it gets out there
people will people get into it next
question how can I introduce my female
boss to the extreme ownership way
without being offensive just sell it as
improvement given the chance before give
the book to her and tell her
that you read this book and you really
like it and you want to become a better
leader and if she could read it and keep
you in check if she sees you getting out
of line you'd appreciate it and just let
her read it yeah
then let them let the book work it's
funny you guys are talking about this is
the muster I think late may be said it
may be they said I don't know but you're
like I'll tell you how you don't do it
yeah throw the book at her and say you
need to square yourself away read this
book in a horse not good no next
question do you experience loneliness
while at the top it's lonely at the top
you've heard that expression yeah yeah
yeah it's lonely at the top if so how
did you handle it you know actually not
really and I guess for me from my
perspective I look at the top being when
I was in leadership position walls
platoon commander or at asking a
commander or the commander of the
training detachment was it lonely it's
not really man I had friends and people
that I hung out with and people that I
would trust to talk and have
conversations with and so that wasn't
really a fact and then on top of that I
actually don't really mind being alone
it's not a big deal to me I don't feel
lonely when I'm by myself I'm fine yeah
somebody asked me the other day are you
an introvert or an extrovert yeah and I
was like mom probably both and they're
like no no but you have to be one of
course cuz right right they said so
let's do it yeah and and I said I said
well I don't care I I literally don't
care like if I'm gonna run with a bunch
of people okay if I'm in a room with by
myself don't care whatever bring it yeah
no big deal yeah I think the extrovert
if I'm not mistaken like like as the
need you know like he's there they're
like attracted to you know other people
being there yes so I guess that's I said
I'm like yeah that's fine whatever don't
care yeah alone so so yeah you know what
I always like I said I had friends that
I trusted and more weren't like we're
good enough friends that they weren't
gonna be trying to get their own gain
out of being my friend you know people
that were friends with me before I was
in a leadership position and people
remain friends after so yeah it's not
that big of a deal to me you know luck I
guess I'm lucky cuz I mean it must be a
thing everyone says it yeah and I guess
me being in like I'll tell you what you
do you do you work I'll take this this
is what you when you when you're out
when you're at the top when you're a an
owner or you're the leader there's times
where you have to do things by yourself
yeah there's no doubt about that
and if you have a problem with that you
you're gonna have a problem being a
leadership position because there's
things that you have to do is leader you
have to lead from the front you have to
work harder you have to do extra you you
should be working harder than everyone
else when you're in a leadership
position of an organization no doubt
about it and if you're not working
harder that's not good and if you're if
you're working harder there's gonna be
times when you're not with anyone else
and you have to be ok with that
and I'm perfectly okay with that don't
there yeah and that's actually what when
that's what that expression means it's
lonely at the top meaning like you're at
the top because you're willing to in a
general way of putting it behave or be a
certain way that other people either
care yeah yeah right so you're not gonna
be able to relay from that perspective
it you're definitely lonely at the top
yeah there's no one that's gonna sit
there and do what I'm willing to do yeah
to be there yeah like where are you at I
don't know haven't seen you but I'm
gonna pee by myself but I'm gonna keep
getting after it right that's out of the
way yeah that's how people end up in
those positions yeah you don't end up in
those positions you don't get gifted
positions you don't just get end up I
just couldn't say never but I didn't yes
sir yeah had to grind it out keep
grinding it out I think yeah you know
what think about this question I think
this did what you said doesn't surprise
me at all cuz II as a human being I
think we all kind of maybe sometimes we
do sometimes we don't admit that it is
good and nice to have like someone there
kind of supporting you in this way where
where where you kind of feel like oh
your feelings matter kind of thing
yes I'm super soft but it's like kind of
deep down inside we're like let's say
you know how like you know look no no
listen so even the idea that like people
just don't understand you know that
concept or people just don't get it they
don't understand or whatever yeah so
when you go to the top that feel
is everyone everywhere the people just
don't understand this is the difference
I don't look at in people in the
negative light because they don't get it
I'm fine with it
yeah like I recognize that what I'm I
recognize that I'm not a hundred percent
normal yeah
and I'm not yeah they're not I don't
look down right I actually I said this
word I just get interviewed oh I got
interviewed on a business insider by and
and he's like well do you always keep
your discipline I was like no people get
all the SEAL Teams and they get fat and
they don't care anymore and it's like I
don't I don't care about that I'm stoked
you know that means they're stoked and
eating breakfast in bed and they're
hanging out with their kids it's all
good I don't I don't have a negative
opinion of them just like I don't have a
negative opinion of someone that
prioritizes things differently than me
it's fine
yeah it's perfectly fine yeah I get it
that that's what point and I'm okay yeah
I'm okay with that and I'm not looking
around going wow I wish I had more
people to hang out with it's only up
here that's exactly what lonely at the
top is though yeah yeah and there's a
there was when I was in my first seal
platoon we went to Guam oh we got there
there was a guy and I don't know who did
it I don't know where this I don't know
who this was but there was a seal that
left like a surf ski you know what that
is
no it's basically like a kayak that you
sit on top of anyways and there's a
little a little a little note to himself
it said the higher the fewer yeah
meaning like hey when you because he was
training hard for what I don't know who
it was
does that the higher you higher the
fewer so that's the same thing yeah I'm
an issue with it yeah make sense
yeah man so like you know when you're in
the office working you know tell kids to
cuz that's a whole bullying thing as
people kids kids get the feeling that
being alone is bad yeah like being alone
is not a bad thing you should be
comfortable being alone yeah yeah and as
a normal human being it's key I think
for the most part okay being alone is
one thing but being alone with no choice
is another so like you if you you know
you're at the office cuz you just grind
all day you're at the tops only at the
top whatever you're in the office you're
working everyone else is out you know
Thanksgiving whatever but you're working
cuz you got to work you're at the top
you're still better but you're working
you know kind of thing some people not
you some people
we'll be like men you know like I'm in
this top position but I give up like all
these you definitely give things you
know and yeah exactly right but again
you say you're okay with it I get it of
course yeah but if it gets to a point
where I'm not okay with it then I adjust
the balance there you go
okay that's how you deal with there but
you're gonna be playing the long-term
game yeah not the short-term
gratification would you ever consider
being in the reboot of the office all
you mentioned off okay that's why that's
the guy I'd read the questions earlier
bang so is it kind of in my head layers
do you like Dwight Schrute the best
route to Disney right Shrek shrewd eye
Dwight Schrute what's wrong with you
Schrute farms yeah the office is a great
show and my kids are obsessed with the
office for some reason so I watched the
office sometimes in them there's a
British version of the office and I
actually prefer the British version of
the office hmm I guess because it's just
my personality but the British version
the office is kind of depressing no it's
funny but it's kind of depressing
because the American one goes over the
top the characters are over the top
they're an extreme yeah so they're funny
you go oh that's funny
Toofer for the boss to have that
attitude it's a caricature yeah the
British one is toned back just enough
that it's more realistic and it's it's a
little bit depressing and that's what my
kid I told my kids you gotta watch the
British one the British one is much
better and my kids watch them like I
don't want to watch that it's depressing
so yeah that's great and Dwight Schrute
is an awesome character yes because it
kind of because everyone knows Dwight
Schrute
who's Dwight Schrute he's a character in
the office which one though I mean I've
seen it and stuff but I don't know the
names of the guys he's a guy with
glasses okay yeah it's self defense and
yeah yeah dorky
okay so you would be in it they're like
reboot of the office hey chuckle we want
you to be on a tight route or whoever I
could be yeah what's the main guy's
named Michael right the character I mean
yeah the boss yeah Mike actually what's
funny is when you watch that show you
can see leadership issues you see the
glaring leadership issues a good little
good little lessons learned for
leadership in there yeah sure so who do
you be who's your choice hey jungle oh
oh I'd have to be one of the people that
are in there yeah yeah this is will
reboot Ashland it would be cool to be a
super hardcore version of Dwight Schrute
like a Ledge yeah for our core version
of Droid sure that'd be pretty funny
well isn't the hole cut like comic
genius behind the character Dwight
Schrute is that he's so dorky like a
Napoleon Dynamite type guy right like
he's like so dorky buddy's like yeah
this Burke or Dwight Schrute so you
could be safari core but it'd be inverse
you'd be you'd be dis dorky like you're
doing you know I treat is trying to sell
the his hardcore Ness but he's just
don't you take any character to the
extreme it can be funny yeah so in your
case actually if you if you like when
I'm on Twitter I take my character sure
you know where someone says what's
what's a good dessert steak right just
having fun yeah right yeah you like that
text message too by the way
so yes the your character is hard core
underlying hard core that's like the
known thing one but then you're trying
to be all I don't know like smart or
something like you know like like this
is it this is for the the repo the
reboot yeah yeah I'm not worried about
it man that's how it is almost a classic
well huh that next question has seen
kids in hell holes ever made parenting
harder for you Olivia you're not living
kids not really when I was overseas and
you'd see kids in horrible situations it
just makes you appreciate the
opportunity that you have to provide for
your kids and to try and help those kids
as much as you can so I don't think it
made parenting harder for me yeah yeah
it makes you appreciative
yeah well the opportunities that we have
for sure yeah I feel like
I know that question where yeah one if I
see like kids and elves it it doesn't
make it harder but it makes it like
you're more sensitive you know like it's
tough just affects you more with your
kids I don't know in my experience
that's what happens because you kind of
can't like it messes you up when you see
like like my wife will read like
trafficking like human trafficking arms
and stuff and you see we're going to be
pictures or video whatever and so it
kind of leaves a mark in your brain so I
don't know maybe you're just playing
everyday kind of stuff and you see your
kid and you're like dang you can't help
but remember those pictures didn't do a
comparison
oh yeah and well that's well that'll
make you paranoid do in a good way yeah
yeah yeah be careful with your kids
there's evil people out there yeah sure
next question how do you reduce your
bosses anxiety levels do a really good
job you don't I mean yeah head of the
power curve do a really good job keep
them informed and kick ass and that's
how you relieve your boss's anxiety step
up yeah that's that's good advice for
your wife too by the way relieving your
wife's anxiety else yeah for sure take
lead right not lead like oh you know
call all the shots necessarily but you
know if if if you guys are trying to
figure out where to go for dinner boom
call it call it man don't be like oh
whatever you want don't do that don't
create the leadership void mmm don't do
that jerk I learned that from you by the
way
next question trying to keep in shape
while traveling long term and not use
not having gym access as an excuse for
letting my standards slip best pieces of
kit training styles for maintaining
conditioning and adding mass while
living out of the back get rings yeah
get rings get gymnastics would gymnastic
rings why would cuz plastic or metal
will make you you get sweaty and slep
and you have to bring a ton of chalk you
need a little bit of chalk with wood
rings it's a little morbid there's the
best thing to grab onto so ya get wood
gymnastic rings you can carry him
anywhere
and then just do a bunch of calisthenics
I mean come on man just knows what
adding mass how do you add mescaline are
you gonna get creative yeah you gotta
get creative but it's you know when
instead of doing squats you know air
squats do jump squats so you're doing
some dynamic you know 1y metrics yeah
I'd do one-legged pistols yeah all that
stuff yeah yeah that's the I got to do
that right now
like I can't you can't drill the hole in
my mm-hmm
so they drilled a hole and they attach
the tendon not in the hole they go to
push the tendon through the hole they
put an anchor at the end of it
boom anyway a lot of swelling in the
forearm you can't grab nothing you can't
grab anything and have weight you know
so calisthenics you got to kind of make
your position your wrists in a position
in a like a comfortable position you can
do calisthenics anyway point there is
I'm in that boat lifting weights is not
an option at this very moment for me so
you gotta kind of get creative so like I
push up you can make the push-ups harder
if you put your feet up and the higher
you put your feet you know the harder it
becomes or you do like a one-arm push-up
situation and then you can do like a
decline like um you know you go on a
counter first right okay how many of
these one-arm push-ups you can do more
than 20 okay maybe you go for like a
chair or something like this something
something uh shorter boom you can do
more than 20 of those okay now I can go
to the ground
see I'm saying and then you can go up
and raise your feet up as time goes on
there you go good for and actually
bodyweight through space is the best way
to build size in your muscles there as
far as like exercises go it's good
information it is better than dead
lifting and squatting well okay so that
dead lifting squatting that's gonna be
it's gonna depend on the way but think
about this dead lifting and squatting is
moving your body through space so do an
air squat you're moving your body
through space as a squatting with weight
right come back squat right right but we
don't squat yeah
Duty team heavy with squats yeah but
again like I said moving your body
through space is the aren't the best
exercises for mass what is what is not
moving your body through so like okay I
squat compared to a leg press so I
haven't even though those aren't even in
my those aren't even in my mind I know
brow but this guy asking the question it
might be well I'm trying to help him out
I don't wanna help you out
you got the whole exercise thing figured
out I get it you know you're expert in
your boring workouts talk about that
later nonetheless so the body weights or
body moving your body through space is
the best exercise the problem is or
tends to be that your body has a fixed
amount of weight more or less so you
can't adjust the weight and usually you
can move your body through space a bunch
of times if you do air squats if you do
a bunch of air squats so it doesn't
provide the quote-unquote tension that
you need to build mess that's why you go
one at a time create more tension on
your muscles while still moving your
body through space which could wind up
to be a better exercise for you that's
what I'm saying
that's good hey man whatever Brad don't
act like it's crazy that I'm saying no
that's the question you really the first
roll up with this whole moving your body
through space thing yeah that's real
information I just have no idea what
that I I kind of get it now yeah but you
were saying it as if it was some unknown
it is unknown moving your body through
yes okay so you know what a hammer
strength yes okay so it's all you know
it's like it's like a I don't know like
a lever kind of thing directly it's like
you know you put some plates on it you
push it there's a pulley or nothing but
you know you're not moving your body
through space you know moving your body
through space so I'm kind of creating
the spectrum here so could just consider
that then it's kind of far down there's
other movement or things that are
further down the spectrum but that's
fixed movement there's no balance
required
there's no whatever it's just like
you're just pushing late its isolation
right yeah plane the plane is isolated
all this to the plane of movement cool
right so that will have less
neuromuscular activity when you push it
even if you're pushing heavy weights
then something like graduate to like
barbell bench press right for example
but even that even though you do have to
balance so that's a big step up
but even that you don't have to balance
in certain planes certain planes of
movement you don't have to balance like
the what do you call this one lateral
whatever the lateral movement on a
barbell bench press which is the bar you
don't have to balance it's fixed but
front and back or forward and for the
back whatever you do have to balance so
you know still good now go to dumbbells
now you have 360 degree plane of
movement that you have to balance more
neuromuscular activity so dumbbells are
better than barbells in that way no
muscular activity and you can adjust the
weight so you can do things where you
can only do three reps you can do things
you can do 20 reps if you want so boom
great exercise can't really do it on a
hotel room but just saying generally
speaking good exercise but now you go
the tip top the best exercise for normal
muscular activity would be push-ups
because same thing you're moving your
body through space you're not balancing
weight your balance of some rings okay
even better now you're going like
creative which is good that's like
beyond the spectrum which is good
totally good but so yeah keep these
things in mind I think when you do a
thing weight so if you can add or when
you do workout so when you if you can
add weight that's the challenge if you
can add weight to these moving your body
through space exercises that's what you
need again well I think now I'm just
gonna take this one step further do it
because you don't necessarily have to
add weight as you stated earlier you can
adjust how you're moving your body
through space and then you can get the
you can get additional and I'll tell you
what really makes this obvious is if you
do any gymnastics training if you do a
pull-up that's hard if you do a tuck
pull up where your knees are pulled up
that's even harder if you do a l-sit
pull-up where your knees are up but your
feet are pointed straight forward that's
even harder each one of those things is
a little bit harder the same thing with
a dip like just a regular dip if you've
done your feet hang it's easier if you
bring it up to a talk it's a little
harder if you bring it up to an L it
even harder so you can keep doing these
things and there's squats that you can
do I mean just doing pistols alone
that's a lot harder some people can't
even do pistols yeah and so you might
have to do an assisted pistol to start
off yeah so yeah you can make it happen
pistols got a hard man especially if you
never done before it's hard cuz the
balance
yeah there's no back and side to side
balance our 360 degree plane of
balancing that's what this whole thing
is about moving your body through spaces
that old-school Bulgarian fill
philosophy workout program called this
is the old school never deviated from it
much the core really good too by the way
um it's called our serious growth is
what it's called weird right like that's
such a lame name but man I was in high
school and I was like alright you know
you read all these things right I mean
in the butt back of the you know muscle
magazine or whatever and the little
article I remember all the Bulgarian yes
kind of like that was a big thing
no Bulgarian well yeah because the
Bulgarians were doing really good at
weightlifting yeah quiet no one knew it
was weird and these guys were like yeah
five weeks or four weeks my bench went
up to this you know when you're in high
school band check it I don't get that
order so you get the prominences book
and it's just called serious growth and
it explains everything really in detail
- I was like dang this is pretty good
real plain English - not all those rules
science or whatever and maybe there so
and they were doing keto - by the way
that's where I learned about this 90
that's crazy that's been around for a
long time
well that Atkins book came out this 60s
or 70s that's way different though it's
do not it's not way different way
different yeah this guy's been around
for a long time yeah mark dr. Mario or
Mauro day possible
oh yeah yeah yeah that's it was the keto
guy and again back in the nineties still
around yeah okay so yeah so we did this
thing we get this book and it's like
laying it out and you know I'm down I'm
15 16 years old I'm down the lift five
days a week
do this and bro we did it and you eat
good not like crazy I didn't do the
kiddo never did um but you know they
have an assumption and so we did or
whatever and we it was weird since right
gained like 20 pounds and I just we just
kept doing it so you know you play
football you can't really gain there's
also this whole thing that you're 15 and
your body's just filled with
testosterone you were gonna gain 16
pounds anyway it's not a teen balance
I'll tell you this right now I'll suck
it in Jodie Minich about this briefly -
I'll tell you this right now if even at
40 you go on this thing it depends on me
no no go on this this type of work and
I'm not even like selling this work out
or nothing like that
this'll people will think and think you
know what though okay people think
you're on steroids if you do this
workout for like six weeks that's it six
weeks they'll think you're on Sarah
straight-up like my whole life when I'd
like go on apirana like a six week thing
they're all he's on Sarah it's obviously
he's answer no Sirians you only have to
take supplements that's the weird thing
but here let me say this though now that
I'm thinking of it as or about it when
I'm a grown adult most programs if you
actually do the whole proof people just
don't do the work
Oh what do you need to do lift heavy
weights a lot eat good and rest good
yesterday outside yeah you'll get yawns
and let's and let's face it it's not is
like if someone says oh yeah it's easy
here's the thing it's not easy this is
why it's not easy it's not just the
workout that's why you have to do the
workout then you have to eat enough of
the right things do by the way and then
you have to rest enough that's basically
you have to change your whole life so if
you're like it's easy just change your
whole life
it's not easy no so and not that I'm not
saying that that's a good excuse or
anything but I'm just saying it's not
quote-unquote easy but yeah there it is
Jack do wear a diet exercise eat good
workout fit in rest good you'd be good
hotel or gym easy that's actually here's
what you can do here's what I do when I
go to the muster or wherever if I'm
there for like a week like the last
muster all like going google maps and
find like all the gyms and be like
alright I'm gonna keep that's kind of
the commitment
obviously you know that's an interest
that's your commitment like you want to
stay in shape add mass as you say
conditioning adding mass whatever look
for the gym near your house commit to
pay that gym feeds geez like what 10
bucks or something like that and boom
that's the commitment right do that
that's what I do
same thing would you just by the way
next question forgive or wait to settle
the score you know what this is kind of
a question that okay so forgive if you
can forgive people for that's cool yeah
now here's the thing you've got that
little thing eaten in the back your mind
because you want to settle the score I
know I do you really don't have yet no I
tell you like hey just forgive and
forget right but but it's hard to do
that sometimes especially if they're all
certain situations merit you know a
little bit it's hard to make that happen
a little little something extra special
but this is what's interesting forgiving
someone is actually a form of settling
the score maybe you can think about this
so for me the best revenge you can take
on someone is success right is ignoring
them and the best revenge is not even
letting them know that you even think
about them anymore
yeah that's the best revenge in my mind
so you forgive them and you just move on
I think that's the best thing to do
forgive them move on and go kick ass in
the world and the little part of your
brain that will really wants to take
revenge you'll be taking the best
possible revenge you can you'll be doing
it in the best possible way and it'll be
the best for you as a human being yeah
so that's what you do yeah yeah I
forgive you and then you go kick ass
yeah forgiving someone for real like for
real for real forgiving them is really
hard even if you do take the high road
behavior wise on the inside it's like
you kind of don't there's this guy in
high school and actually wasn't even
high school was you're still holding
high school grudges no uh yeah I guess
technically yeah it's still there
like if there was not like if you were
to see I don't know something
good that I did like now and be like oh
man he's doing good that would give me
satisfaction right now so yeah
technically yet still that little
something yeah but if it's to forgive
someone fully to be to to a point where
oh yeah if you saw that I was doing
great now or something like that and
that wouldn't move me either way to get
to that point is we're super hard so I
think just like I you said like the
behavior that you want to kind of you
want to enact yeah is is yeah don't let
it bother you and here's the thing with
don't not letting it not not letting
bother you don't let it affect you at
all like no factor like you almost like
you didn't even notice kind of here okay
so that's hard to do this right AC you
were there yes you can do that can go
that off bread that's the worst for the
other hand saying so like you ever you
ever had like good bro get this is where
like did I see you know you think to
yourself think did I see something to
piss that guy off whoever it is whatever
I don't know somebody where that girl or
whatever did I say something are they
offended or whatever and you just don't
quite know but it's not big enough to
bring up so you can't bring it up and
get that satisfaction of knowing you
know but if they don't just don't say
any let's say they were offended say
don't even like you but they just don't
don't like talk to you rather than if
they ignore you or don't acknowledge
that you said something or something
like that that's way more that bothers
you way more than them like cussing you
out or something or yelling at you're
like I'm super mad at you in it them
telling you they're mad at you is way
more like satisfying yeah
than them not if you just ghost them
forgive them and move on yeah but if you
ghost them you can't overly ghost like
you get overly analyst be like yeah like
yeah that's why it's good for you if
you're mad at someone and they text you
like hey you know only if you give them
like one-word answers or you don't text
them back that messes with them way
worse then you say yes I'm mad at you
and you hurt me and you piss me off or
whatever and all these
don't bet I learned it for me breath
Jack good advice right there good advice
next question when you you've crushed
your daily to-do list do you then take
the time to relax or do you tack the
next day's list is that against
prioritize and execute since the mission
is done for the day
you know just do more just keep going
even if it's going do more if you have
extra time do whatever you can do to
stay ahead and I do that pretty much
until I'm brain dead and I can
definitely work myself into it until I'm
brain dead like I can get to a point
where I'm reading or I'm writing it just
it's just it's just done I'm done
and so I just have to stop and take a
break and then I'll go do something
mindless for a while
you know so you know if you if you got
stuff to do keep hammering until you
can't hammer anymore and then say okay
you know what I need a little breather
and then take a little breather and then
get back to it
right now I could work 24 hours a day 24
hours a day yeah 7 days a week 365 days
a year and and I wouldn't be able to get
done things I'm trying to get done so
it's not like I'm sitting there going oh
cool I got a break no yeah all I got is
more stuff to do get you got things to
do
so not a bunch of Boise call it breaks
and it's relaxing it's not not a lot of
that happening right now now you go
surfing is that a break kind of it's
like a big break well it's kind of hard
of the process it's like if you're doing
five sets of 10 on the bench what are
you gonna do one set of 50 no you define
set to 10 so first that's a 10 what do
you do you got a rescue to recover
that's what surfing is that's it's the
rest between sets that's all that is
right there you go start of the process
track but what you would you recommend
for someone who's like a normal person
do what you can knock it out build up
extra free time if you need a break take
a break that's pretty crazy right no
what I'm saying is that you're doing
what you can if you need a break take a
break if you need a little relaxation
take some relaxation
you know waste your time no see people
people do relaxing but they do it they
don't even do it good
they haven't feel relaxed when they get
done it's not productive relaxing yeah
they just what they did is they did
something stupid for an hour
they watched YouTube videos for an hour
yeah did that help you know go outside
go for a run do some burpees go surfing
go do some jujitsu play with your kids
whatever do something that actually has
some value yeah the real value but so
what about you know piranhas and we're
going to the bar yeah that's not great
but sometimes you need to hammer because
you're hungover the next day you can't a
comp you know you can't function as good
boom can't your output your productivity
goes down next day you better tell
everyone amines because not everyone
knows Hana I guess technically it means
done with what you're doing poverty is
done Hana means like do yeah but yeah
Pau Hana finishing what you're doing tip
it's referred to when you're finished
with work yeah that's the way I was used
it yeah yeah when you finish work Paul
Hana yeah you know whatever it's like
miller.time you know kind of the same
thing a little bit next question would
you recommend jiu-jitsu for a 55 year
old female with no former martial arts
background is the risk for injury too
high yeah answer this one a bunch of
times hey yes you should do jiu-jitsu
pick good training partners get you ego
out of the picture and go very slow and
learn the techniques and you'll get
something out of it yeah watch out first
sparring rolling live you need to be
really careful and you need to really
select good training partners that are
very much more experienced than you are
don't roll with white belts if you're a
55 don't even roll with blue belts if
you can help it as a 55 year old unless
they're small and smart just be careful
but yeah it's a great train it's a great
thing
what about because I actually got asked
this online and I was actually through
dm's like going through it was a girl
Taylor if I'm not mistaken first thing
anyway she's black belt and she you know
when it comes to girls rolling just even
just regular girls or whatever let's
face it I mean in training they do have
a bigger kind of kind of obstacle in
that way where they're at they are at a
higher risk of injury
because everyone if they're rolling with
the guys I mean everyone chances are
everyone's bigger than them and they
might be going hard and they'd you know
some guys especially early on they don't
realize that dang they're putting a lot
of strength and you know all the stuff
into these moves again going hard
exhausted relaxed where they do have
this obstacle even 55 year old lady or
even just an older person in general
they do have that added obstacle where
yeah you do have to kind of so what's
the question
yeah the question is like what do those
people do yeah same deal yeah no they
have to be more extremely cautious they
have to take more caution you're a
hundred percent right what you're saying
is right you do and what it's what I
just said you don't want to go with a
psycho white belt you don't even want to
go with any white belt right because
they're there they don't know what
they're doing so go with someone that's
a purple belt someone that's relaxed
they're the a 55 year old woman is gonna
be on a different pace down the path
gonna be on the path which is at a
different pace yeah and and the stress
is - I would focus on the the learning
of the technique a lot more you know
it's been a lot more time drilling and
learning the technique and then
occasionally with your black belt
instructor with your brown belt
instructor with some of the high-level
purple belt smart people you do a nice
little roll with them you have some fun
you see what works what doesn't work you
learn a little bit more take that path
take that pace down the path all right
don't go in there with a big ego and you
know what happens every time like if you
introduce jiu-jitsu to people they think
that they have the solution to something
that you teach right and it's like no
you don't actually have the solution you
don't know anything so just just don't
do that he is at the muster and you know
we teach jiu-jitsu for the first time to
a bunch of people and we were teaching
the umpa right the the Oba escape the
robot escape where you roll the person
over from the mountain and this one guy
you know he's like I'm teaching mushroom
this one guys like I
look this doesn't work and he's got his
weight all the way in the other side
he's got his leg up I remember that yeah
yeah and I'm like I'm like yeah there's
another move you just do this Popo and
now you're in the guard and but like in
his mind like jujitsu just does it
wasn't doesn't doesn't work I don't know
what this crap is that jock was all into
but obviously doesn't work no actually
it works so you don't you don't uncover
the magic of jujitsu in one moment yeah
you know yeah oh actually you know what
I do remember the question so you know
how it can fit five year old women roll
with you know high-level people people
that you trust people who have like a
lot of control over this situation
what about like let's say I you know I'm
a 55 year old woman I have a twin sister
she's 55 we're in the same shape kind of
thing just normal people and can we roll
you better be careful you better calm
down you better knock it competitive you
better relax mmm
now one thing that's good as I would say
yes actually yeah I would say yes think
you know why because you're around
equivalent strength you're around
equivalent knowledge you still got to be
careful yeah I prefer you go a couple
six months before before you jump in and
do a death match with your twin sister
at age 55 yeah I know you you've been
compete watts each other so just just
try and relax you know I see Jade trying
to kill you like dude come on
when Jade used to Train no sorry oh yeah
yeah sure he could check no I know
that's I'm saying he tried it's funny
the G even from birth Jade was a little
bit bigger than me not anymore no no no
and I think it's literally a direct
result of it of all moving a little bit
usually in complex yeah like a little
small medium and you know when that
happened he was bigger than me through
high school through uh even through
college he was bigger than me until we
were done kind of with college and also
just gonna lift and I'm ballooned up to
like almost 250 250 and then he was like
were you athletic when you're 250 yeah
surprisingly yet now would you go back
up there again I was it as a fluff you
know you know a grown adult it doesn't
make sense for me I'm not tall I don't
know this is my opinion and plus in
while you lean 250 not as lean as I am
now no I wouldn't call myself lean or
cut but I wasn't fat though that's a
thing I even have this old picture of me
and my friend Scotty unless he's a cop
now by the way he we're like because he
would lift it with you partner jackets -
oh yeah big and we were like this is
when I was like 245 he was like maybe
230 or something like that and yeah I
was big but I was like that was like
surprisingly defined though I got it at
250 one time
oh that's and then I went and ran a four
mile run you know and I did not feel
good yeah and I was like okay I'm done
with this yes meanwhile I was pumped to
be 250 just cuz you know yes thank you
but I don't need a four mile run I was
like good god this is horrible
yeah I can't do my job and that's yeah
that's the answer why you don't wanna be
250 and even be like that's a huge
amount of weight even health-wise
especially as you get older whatever I
like to be just rolling around 250 you
know yeah yeah and if you can't do a
four mile right if you can't do it I'm
probably thinking back like even a one
mile run would have been kind of kind of
more difficult that would have liked at
250 that's not a good sign yeah that's
that's how it went
so yeah the point there being I got
bigger than than Jade boom and with that
little micro Napoleon complex it critten
like I was more like aggressive or am
even still not like more like I'll take
up more aggressive like I started you
more more aggressive
that's one because I don't think of it
that way you think Jane I think Jayde's
more aggressive maybe like to get in
like a debate or something yeah it's
definitely addressing yeah but but yeah
a physical activity I probably start
dude I was like before Jade sorry I was
like well into purple belt yeah for Jane
even started and that's a big gap so
yeah Jake can try to kill me he will not
kill me
he just simply won't it's almost
impossible it's pretty much impossible
technically in public if there's ammo uh
so if you go a percentage rate chances
of him ever beating me
percent of the percent chance of him
beating me is closer to zero than it is
1% true that's how it is right now
unless you went on the complete warpath
Oh
what do you mean if he trained well yeah
that goes for every but hurt Lee that's
how it is yeah so he's a zero percent
he's off the path doesn't matter he can
get on the path still zero percent
chance next question I'd like to hear
your thoughts on people entering the
military in their 30s I'm sure you saw
it
how'd they fare entering the military at
an older age is fine you got maturity
you got experience you got intelligence
and so that's good you're gonna bring a
lot to the table however you also have
maturity experience and intelligence so
the only downfall of it is you got to do
some dumb stuff when you're in the
military and and and if you're older and
you see how dumb some of the stuff that
you're doing is it's gonna be harder for
you to do it you're gonna have a little
bit of a negative attitude on if you
allow yourself it'd be easy to say that
if you allow yourself it'd be easy to
develop a negative attitude about that
stuff I joined when I was 18 years old I
didn't care you want me to do whatever
you want me to do I'll do it I didn't
see the stupidity and a lot of stuff and
so I think that's the only drawback
because you'll just be looking at some
of the stuff that you do in the military
thinking oh I this is much more
efficient way to do this and if you let
that get to you it's gonna be
problematic so go in there with an open
mind do the crap the the tedious and
kind of mindless stuff that you got to
do and push through that and then you'll
get to a position of leadership and you
can do your best to mitigate that and
take care of other soldiers sailors
airmen and Marines while you're out
there serving the country so yeah it's
awesome it's great you'll you'll be a
big benefit do you think that that even
that um how you're saying like okay
you'll you'll you kind of look at things
in more of an adult way kind of thing
where it's like all this more efficient
way to do something do you think that
that mindset would kind of keep you from
you know being more cohesive do with if
you allow it to it definitely will if
you if you that's what I said you have
to allow if you just go look this is
this is the way it is right now I'ma be
one in the military they're telling me
to do this thing it doesn't make any
sense right now I'm gonna do it to the
best of my ability
move forward if you say all this is
stupid and you spread the negativity the
other guys why are we doing this yeah
it's gonna be problematic some go in
there have a good attitude you can
promote really quickly if you're squared
away like that you know so you got a
good opportunity out of you under this I
think it's totally good to go
what about even like socially you know
like connive oh yeah these these are 18
you've been out in the world you've had
a job you probably have a house you
might have kids these kids are I I was
out of high school like you know what I
mean it's you're not there yet you're
and you think about what you know when
you're that age compared to what when
you fit when you're 30 yeah you know my
big thing is I tell my kids all the time
you know or like my oldest daughter
who's in college and whatnot and I'm
always like when I was your age I was my
first seal platoon you know like you
just can't even compete with what I was
doing the responsibility that I had when
I was 18 years I know all that stuff um
but but the truth is when you're 18
you're not as mature as you are when
you're 30 so yeah there'll be a social
disc and act like I went to college when
I was I think it was 28 or 29 or 30 and
so yeah I was around kids that were 18
19 years old and I realized very quickly
that you know you'd meet some mature
kids but a lot of kids were just they're
just young yeah I mean there's not a big
difference between 18 and 15 for some
people right yeah you think about what
you were doing you were 15 years old 16
years old like I joined the military so
luckily I had some kind of structure
imposed upon me yeah but you think about
the kind of stuff that you can do when
you're 18 years old people do dumb dumb
dumb stuff yeah you you you look back
and you're happy that you made it you
dumb dumb stuff yeah no we're talking
about wasting your time on YouTube
videos go waste your time on YouTube
like just put in Latino teenagers doing
dumb stuff and you'll you'll say wow and
in 50% of the stuff that you see you'll
recognize yeah oh yeah I remember that
you know so yeah don't do dumb stuff and
it has a 30 year old in the military you
can help give some of that guidance to
people so I think it's cool go for men
and kind of vice versa right because
like if you're the 18 year old 19 year
old guy there's like you know
however many other 18 19 year old guys
you guys are cruising then here comes
this 30 year old you know all
level-headed but I can't relate to this
guy this guy's kind of weird the other
thing is when you're 18 you don't even
know how much those thirty year olds
know you just think you're there you
actually think you know more than at
them like the idiots like why would you
not you know swing off this rope and see
if you can get through the window on the
third floor why did you not give so
that's something I would be out brace
yourself for that to remember the
perspective of an 18 year old and
they're not looking at you going gosh
I'd really like to looking at you like I
can't believe you joined the military
what's wrong with you yeah oh man there
is there were guys who actually came
from the military and still eligible
right for football college and when I
was 26 when I was 27 and let's think
let's face it 26.7 that's young that's
you're physically like your solid still
and we looked at them like man these are
like these are old-school guys these are
like old practice literally it was like
I felt like that for one of the guys
anyway and then you go to class right
and you get these people who you know
they they don't go to college right
after high school they go you know later
on when in my opinion when most of us
should go when you know why you're going
and so this one lady was in my class she
was maybe 35 36 whatever didn't look at
you with disgust all day long now she
didn't look at me at all oh well she
freaking like into donor on program yeah
yeah like I was no factor in her life
she was doing yeah literally the correct
way to do it she sat up front no weirdo
you know and she's asking questions
brogre protocol literally and that's
really the way to go when you think you
know you have to think about that's the
way to go but nonetheless she's like
this but she's obviously 30-something
years old and it just didn't compute to
me you know most important things almost
but that's a really key part of this
conversation is when you're 8 imagine as
a 30 year old when you're looking at 18
year old they don't see you know it
won't understand anyway sir so check no
sir we don't
118 next question you've said everyone
will know if you're the one taking
ownership
leading the team in spite of having a
poor leader or someone who does
everything for the glory but what do you
do if your boss's boss doesn't make the
connection between your work and the
team's success good good
you know what I do keep working hard
that's awesome make keep making your
boss look good I recommend that you put
your ego in check because you get that
credit for what for what's happening
you're looking for that glory and
they're there the boss is doing it for
glory well guess what that's making you
mad cuz you want some of that glory yeah
you know what it'll come the two things
about this number one let him have it
make him look great you're worried that
the boss's boss doesn't get it it will
come in due course be patient work hard
give your boss the credit don't worry
about it and in due course it'll come
you you can't fool the boss the boss's
boss won't get fooled forever they won't
get fooled forever and you know what
worst case scenario you get your bosses
you get your boss promoted cool now he
trusts you you work hard for him
you did good he put you can take his
role it's okay hmm it's okay this is
very common this is no strange question
yeah next question what do you do for
fun when you're not getting after it
that's kind of a weird question right
why cuz you're always getting up well
because is surfing getting after it yeah
it is actually it is you're getting
after it yeah it is getting after it is
playing guitar getting after it or yes
it is rock and roll band getting after
it yes it is
okay guess I'm hanging with my kids is
that getting after it
sometimes I kind of it turns what we're
doing guess we were doing jujitsu so
yeah I don't know what I do for fun when
I'm not getting after it just stuff that
I enjoy doing like you said earlier like
it doesn't take discipline to go and do
jujitsu if Jesus is really fun for you
and judges who's definitely fun for me
yeah I would say 70% of the time I'm I'm
like super stoked to be going and roll
30% of the time I don't feel like it I
go anyways I should say 28% of the time
there's like 2% of the time where I
recognize oh I'm gonna get hurt today
cuz I'm beat up or I'm tired or whatever
it's like okay you know what maybe I
won't change it at ya or and even on
those days sometimes I'll come in and
I'll just do a light roll yeah just to
make sure put myself a little discipline
check so yeah that's the kind of the
thing where I guess from other people's
perspective if they're thinking jujitsu
is not fun and working outs not fun and
and and practicing and instruments not
fun well then I'm not ever having any
fun yeah but actually the opposite is
true all those things are fun for me so
I'm having fun all the time there you
know yeah it kind of kind of goes in
line with them that other question of
mindless like do you ever do mindless
stuff so maybe that's kind of another
work oh yeah
yard work cleaning the garage stuff like
that but you know actually you know what
it is now that I think of it it's the
question could be could be do you what
do you do fun meaning what do you do
like mindless stuff that's that's not
technically productive so you say turf
surfing productive I don't know though
it's one of those things but you know
what you feel good when you get on the
water I mean you get a little workout it
is because you get better at surfing
yeah so it is kind of product but
there's no there's no productivity to
surfing there's no there's no ultimate
goal other than doing it itself yeah
same thing with guitar but you're
getting better at guitar true so like
even like yard work for example it's
like sure that's nuts
yeah your mind yeah that's productive
you're improving it's productive it's so
what you're asking me is what do i do
that's completely unproductive
productive yeah
I don't know right now there's not a lot
hardest wish to the world there's not a
lot of things right now that I'm doing
that aren't somehow productive yeah I
think but it is because tech mere off on
though because that was the actual
question you're just trying it yeah I'm
all assuming the you you know because
watching YouTube back to the course I'm
watching YouTube videos of like yeah
like trade gone YouTube actually don't
do it but if you do do it do this go but
the in the search in YouTube go drunk
girl fails okay that's what it's called
strong girl fails okay so this probably
maybe 500,000 to 10 million of these
videos potentially that's my estimate
yeah so what that means is once you're
done with one the other ones coming and
here's the thing it never gets old
so that is actually I do think it gets
old
alright well yeah that was more of like
an exaggeration but it takes a long time
I would argue for most of us for it to
quote unquote get old
so the point there is that is something
that is straight up not productive true
you can learn less much of that the
lessons to be learned from those videos
get learned literally the first video
yeah literally and then well no they
don't get learned in the first video
because the first one just seems like it
could be an anomaly it's like when you
tap them someone that's never done
Juju's before it takes like three or
four before they go okay I get it you're
right that you know something I don't
know so you gotta watch three to five
drunk girl fail videos with your you
know sixteen-year-old daughter and say
like this is why you don't get drunk
yeah this is why yeah actually you don't
believe me okay watch two more and we'll
see if there's any of these things that
you would want to see yourself behaving
yes yeah but and you could argue that
maybe if you want 5 6 7 10 20 you start
to see another pattern get revealed
within the pattern of drunk girl fails
so one of them is you know a girl
writing a skirt around this pass to you
know not like not just don't get drunk
but don't ride scooter exactly exactly
right we don't dance on the bar when
drunk yes exactly right so if you see
let's say within the span of 15
girl fail videos you see you know 30 of
those is girls dancing on the bar versus
only two of them were girls on a scooter
you can kind of discern that dancing on
the bar statistically right I'm the same
way we're digging for lessons you know
that's so that's a bad thing
dissing digging for glasses is a bad
thing that's where that wasn't a lesson
bro sorry
digging for lessons next question
virtuosity requires your favorite
subject discipline creativity is
important as well does a single focus on
discipline inhibit creativity no Jimmy
Page next question seriously Jimmy Page
okay Jew bitch Led Zeppelin guitar
virtuoso practiced with discipline I
just answered this on the kids podcast
okay
because Jimmy Page played guitar so much
when he was in school that they had to
take his guitar from him during like
study halls during lunch like no you
can't just sit there and play guitar you
need to do other things
that's how much he practiced yeah he
practiced so much he became such a such
a skilled player through that much
discipline that he was able to get more
creative than almost anyone else on the
guitar so there you go it doesn't give
you freedom it it expands your
creativity yeah
and Jimmy Page is one example of a
multitude so let me ask you this I guess
we kinda talked about but not never
really actually asked you that I can
remember so if you and let's assume that
Jimmy Page he didn't do it because he
felt like this is you know that what I
should be doing right now whatever he
did just because I'm addicted to guitar
I love it and there's nothing I'd rather
be doing and all this stuff so if you
the question is if you just love doing
it and that's why you're doing it so
much I love guitar I don't want to eat
dinner right now I'm busy on my guitar
and just you know enjoying myself and
learning and just loving it every single
moment of it I don't want to go surf I'm
on my guitar boom every single day is
that discipline yes okay because let's
say okay
actually I don't know I guess not
technically yeah go it is it is it is
but the yeah I'd be a hard press to find
somebody that loves doing something so
much that they do it all the time with
no discipline whatsoever
yeah then in I think I agree with you
there but technically is that discipline
though cuz you know take Michael Jordan
a for example that's not a good example
what I'm about to say I think the guitar
example is good because if you really
love doing it and that's what you're
doing I'll tell you what takes
discipline even if you enjoy it yeah I'm
gonna stick with that answer for now so
let's see might you know any even more
important answers I don't think it
matters I don't think it matters either
so ultimately because it's like it's
because it kind of alter at the end of
the game it did you put in enough hours
of practice and did you get good at it
okay did you get good at it that's what
it what the questions were did you get
good at this thing usually I'll take all
the time pretty much with very few
exceptions the way you get good at
something is practice and then you know
usually since you can't do one thing all
day every single day for you know 30 40
50 years it's gonna take discipline
meaning you're gonna have to do it even
though you don't want to do it kind of
thing which is part of what discipline
is but what if that part of it it
doesn't isn't there cuz even like
Michael Jordan he's so good and he's
probably loved basketball whatever but
there's of course days where he's like
okay I'd rather maybe there's something
else but I'm gonna take displacer
example right right but that is a real
person as
to get a person that loves something so
much that it took them zero discipline I
don't think that's a realistic person I
think that anyone that does anything it
gets to a point where the only thing
that drives them to do that extra
percentage is discipline so I guess I
will stick with it yes I guess the
question if you want to kind of relate
it to like a real person so you know a
person who again just like loves it it
just loves what they do of course
they're gonna have some discipline
they're gonna have some days that they
don't love it or whatever like are they
would you consider them a disciplined
person in their in their field yeah but
we've also talked about this before just
people that are very disciplined in one
field and completely undisciplined in
other fields
yes oh so it's kind of an indicator that
might not really be technically
discipline technically they got the
practice again we get some hours give
you work if you like it that's great if
you don't like it here's appears an
indicator if you if you don't like doing
it well what are you doing it for mmm
you don't even enjoy it I mean the end
right dance to the did it to the end or
whatever means to an end
but if you're gonna dedicate level 12 to
something that you don't even enjoy I
think that's kind of problematic I think
you're right too next question when you
realize that nothing will change in the
leadership do you tap out and move on or
continue trying to be a good leader to
your crew who deserves it that's
definitely a question that it requires a
little bit more information to give a
good answer to you know because what's
the situation can you be is there an
opportunity that you could become the
leader long term because that totally
changes the outlook right if you could
if you could do a good job and step up
and move on to a more senior leadership
position where you could take even more
turn turns or take even more care of the
crew well then that's a positive thing
and it might be worth hanging out for
also is it a complete dead end like is
there no possibility it's a family-owned
business and all the senior leadership
is related to the family and you're not
part of the family and you never have a
chance mmm that that changes the
prospect I mean obviously that's like
okay well maybe
not worse take another if you leave can
you leave where you can give open the
opportunity for other people to go where
you're going right which is not a good
thing in terms of you know you're not
being very loyal you're being anti loyal
you're being unloyal disloyal if you do
that but if the leadership that you're
working for isn't taking care of the
people then you you have to have some
loyalty to the people that you work with
so there's that I think that you you you
have to assess everything that's going
on in the situation which which is not
evident in this one quick question I
would say this - like don't blindside
your boss right that's something that if
you're gonna leave leave on good terms
explain to him what's going on also that
can be an opportunity to start a
conversation about how the leadership
could improve a lot of times people
don't want to change anything until it
really smacks them in the face and one
of the things that smacks them in the
face is when one of their good people
comes in and says hey look I I'm gonna
leave because of these reasons and again
you don't on the exit interview or on
those conversations you don't just drop
dime and make everyone make it out to be
this horrible situation say here's some
things that I've noticed here's some
things that I would want to change
here's the direction that I see the
company going and this is the direction
I think it should be going and for these
reasons I've decided I'm gonna go try
you know try my hand somewhere else I
think if you'd be open like that it can
start some good conversations and
possibly you could make some progress or
possibly you could confirm your
suspicions which are no one wants to
change no one wants to do anything
different and if that's the case and you
realize it's a dead end for you yeah you
got to take that option you you can't
beat your head against though on the
forty you know you can beat your head
against the wall forty seven times on
the forty eight time it's like okay I
need to do something different mmm so
pay attention to that
next wish
what could we all learn from tenacious d
that most people overlook the critical
question it is a critical question but
there's actually a real a real
legitimate answer that and that is that
tenacious d who's a very funny group of
individuals Jack Black is one of them
who's a musician and a comedian and
actor and Kyle Gass is the other member
what's what's great about them is they
don't take themselves too seriously
and I think that's the lesson to learn
is don't take yourself too seriously
have some fun and don't take yourself
too seriously there it is yeah and I
would say there's a difference between
taking yourself seriously and being
serious so you know how like being
serious is like okay you're not letting
necessarily joking all the time but
taking yourself too seriously it's like
you know if like a joke is made about
you or you can't laugh at yourself or
that kind of stuff yeah that's different
so you can be serious all the time you'd
be a serious person and not take
yourself to see that it's true and
that's a good that that's fine that's
like the person you don't want to be is
the person that takes themselves too
seriously all the time yeah that's a
problem so inversely I guess could you
be to like could you be a very not
serious person but take yourself too
seriously could you be a very serious no
could you be a very like jokey not
serious person yes like that's the
person that you can dish it out but you
can't kind of like you right a little
bit yeah yeah see if I see what you did
there
next question unless there's anything
more from Tenacious D no you know maybe
some good songs we can inspirati all
right that's from tonight I gotta give a
warning that language is not appropriate
for kids with Tenacious D ignores some
of the subject matter so be careful with
that
the warning next question you mentioned
you rarely pick play closed guard rarely
is this just a personal preference I
would say that it is somewhat a personal
preference right because there's
definitely some people that
intentionally play closed guard that's
their game but at the same time in order
to attack even from the closed guard
most the time you have to open your
guard so therefore your guard is open so
open guard yeah that's kind of what I do
skip the step of opening my guard but
you've been in people's guard they have
really good close guards yes yeah it's
not fun no and that's why I try not to
let people close their guard yeah cuz
you don't forget that from happening
yeah there's people that have really
really solid psycho closed guard so I'm
not anti closed guard and some people
are great at it my personal preference
is to play more open guard yeah yeah
it's one of those things where closed
guard if you're not a person who always
plays close guard or whatever it can be
just something that you kind of use for
specific situations you know like if
you're trying to maybe breed regain some
energy or something like that you know
rest a little bit or even in like a self
defense like a striking scenario like a
close guard in mind yeah Mike I know the
closed guard is you know there's no
doubt that closed guard has viable
purpose yeah and it's good and I do use
it I don't use it a lot yeah yeah and if
you're a taller lanky guy clothes all
right might be little short fat legs
that you know clothe my clothes guard is
like my toes are touching
depending on the size of the person yeah
and actually where it stems from if you
went to the root of it is it stems from
foot locks so lose your guard when your
guard opens you're vulnerable and that
there's a moment where you're both
vulnerable and if you're training with
guys that have really good four locks
that's not a good situation so that's
where I started not closing my guard
because it was always that transition
period where my feet were vulnerable so
I just stopped closing my garden kept it
open and moved my fit feet towards me to
keep them a little bit safer
yeah next question we got time for one
more yes
yo Jocko what's the best way to include
yo Jocko what's the best way to increase
one's confidence you want to increase
your confidence I'll I'll tell you what
I think what you do if you want to
increase your confidence is you do Jiu
Jitsu you work out you get stronger you
read and you study and you learn and you
get smarter and and then you practice
speaking and you practice speaking so
that you can become more articulate and
then you practice some more and then you
then you do hard things things that are
challenging things that are tough and
then you get tougher
you don't quit that's what you do and
then you stand up straight with your
with your head high then your chin up
and your chest out and at the same time
you also stay humble because you don't
know everything and there are people
that are better than you are at some
things people that are smarter than you
and they're stronger than you and faster
and more athletic than you and they have
more money and they got better looks and
they're funnier but all that is okay
it's actually okay because there are
things that are more important more
important than being strong and smart
and athletic more important than all
those things things like loyalty
on will things like courage the courage
to stand and the will to keep going and
to do the right things for the right
reasons and if you know if you know you
won't give up and you know you won't
give in and if you test yourself and you
fail but you know you're gonna get back
up again if you know that if you know
that then you know that your character
is strong and that's what matters
and that right there is all the
confidence you need and I think that's
all I've got for tonight
so echo yes speaking of being stronger
yes and faster yes and doing jiu-jitsu
sure and learning and just being on the
path overall maybe you could give us
some information on how we can
effectively efficiently move down that
path
yeah support and support ourselves
support ourselves and support others
that's really ultimately really what it
is makes it intellectually supporting
yes so I will talk about our company a
little company in Maine called origin
origin Maine dot-com this is where you
can get choco super krill oil this is
for your joints omega-3s
make it please have a lot of benefits
valuable benefits but the ones that I
personally have read
and you reap benefits you really can't
you just can't reap the foot and Terry
yeah so what's up for that but if you
are in the reaping mood reap some
benefits of choco support krill oil by
way of your joints being healthy it's a
big deal when you're super young like
young 18 19 20 all the websites say like
maybe 27 maybe I don't know maybe older
this is less of a factor but at the end
of the day your joints are healthy
you're gonna be in a way better spot way
better spot then you would be if they're
not also another supplement called joint
warfare this one I mean they all have
antioxidant stuff in them but joint
warfare has glucosamine and chondroitin
this is for what like cartilage a tendon
type stuff and curcumin curcumin yeah so
you put those together boom the ultimate
joint supplements the big deal huge deal
like you can be super strong and be
lifting and but you got to warm up like
for 20 sets just because your joints are
all like stiff and whatever say say bye
to that problem
you take these there it is boom joint
supplements get on it go to or
domain.com also another supplement
called discipline is for your brain
makes your brain work better its
nutrients for your brain that's what it
is
and also nutrients for your body so it's
a pre-workout it's a pre study it's a
pre mission supplement called discipline
get down same same place or domain.com
tastes good too by the way is the other
flavor out when is all the flavor out no
we're making it right now so soon yeah a
little further than soon soon to me is
sort of yeah like a little more distant
and soon
yeah but we're working like shipping
yeah
that's soon to me and it's Pina Colada
by the way I'm sorry I got a different
name for it yeah coconut no I got a
better name for it I got it later well
later okay secret name cuz I'm not sure
to leave :
the name okay guys I have in mind
alright cool
we're all very excited about the name
and the taste and you know what not
pineapple coconut is the working title
working title mmm there you go
cognitive and physical force my
multiplier good one also mulk okay so
smoke I'm gonna say the word protein
powder but I'm not saying moki's protein
powder yeah if you want some additional
protein good way to get it that happens
to taste really really good like a mint
chocolate milkshake not a diet milkshake
I like a mint chocolate milkshake right
and you want protein take more take it
everyday if you want to my buddy sent me
a text he goes yeah I saw that Molk had
probiotics in it dang even better yes
and he said I he said so I just ordered
it because I need some yeah and he's
like yeah I know yeah I said I know and
he's like yeah it's awesome
so anyways making the supersize milk
shake yeah
hey man I can relate cuz that's
literally what I do ya know I could tell
when you got on the market train because
your attitude changed no you went from
like oh yeah we've got more cause it's
good to when you were like hey a game
changer yeah you know what's it's so
failing what does it makes it so filling
filling play like when you eat it you
just feel compiler when you drink it you
feel see she'd completely succeed that's
why you know you know the term meal
replacement yeah like only kind of meal
replacement sir this isn't supposed to
be a meal replacements not supposed to
be the intent was an okay replace but
what happens is if you have it like
yesterday I had one in the in the
afternoon I had a light lunch which was
crap I ate it crap lunch trap like not
many healthy not healthy gotcha little
off the path
so I was feeling like okay and then so
in the a little later than that I said
you know I was gonna have some milk
right now did you reset the path yeah
and then I got home from jujitsu last
night six hours later didn't even barely
eat anything for dinner because I was
still full mmm why is that
amen it's feeling yeah yeah I guess five
satisfies you on multiple fronts yeah
yeah plus psychologically come come on
you kind of knew that it was the mall
can you relax solid you felt good about
that you were satisfied about that
that's probably a big you know factor so
it's not supposed to be a meal
replacement but that's not what it was
imaging the answer it was an engineered
for but it turns out that if you have it
you won't be that hungry because you'd
be so full yeah yes true from oak didn't
do so it's so it's so different we had
to create a different word for it yeah
man that's gonna go be in the Oxford
English Dictionary soon very well it'll
be Oh it'll be they'll have to define it
in the OED you know the OED is an Oxford
English Dictionary yeah yeah that's the
real deal right there that's the big one
yeah that's the big Luke that's the
mother of all dictionaries must be must
be it is
yeah there's no Mustang and milk is
gonna be there you say hey all right
well petition I won't have to petition
for it cuz people are just gonna start
that's how it's just gonna be yeah it's
gonna be how and it really that's how
words get in the dictionary yeah just
keep using it and here's the here's the
good thing about that word not to go off
on too much of a tangent but I will and
I don't want doing it with this
situation
Moke is actual legitimate situation monk
it's milk yeah but it's not like the
word irregardless and you know you're
misusing the word cuz they're not you
know educated on that specific word and
they use your regardless their friend
uses their neighbor uses it there who
knows I'll get in there too welp Ahana
is a Hawaiian word I know but maybe
we'll get it into the English dictionary
but it's not English because that's a
thing then the the English dictionary is
not filled with words that are only
English the whole English language right
above other words got your cousin
in there ray and milk yeah well petition
we can't petition you don't petition to
get him in there you actually just use
the words so like the word forte I
wonder if that's my forte people start
trying to rip off milk yeah
it'll be like hey we use Xerox me a copy
of that right it'll just be the it'll
just be the way yeah yeah instead a new
thing yeah like I'm gonna you know first
I'm gonna work out and then like I'm
just gonna um yeah I'm gonna mold yeah
oh you pick me up some milk from the
store people say well what kind of milk
do and then won't we just be talking
about flavors there'd be nine different
brands of milk okay you're from knit
kind of the East Way is New England east
coast technical for sure as it consider
okay so DeeDee did you grow up in a
place where they say cokes no pop we
call her soda no call it soda yeah we
call the soda too so I've sort okay
that's normal to me in you know as far
as my experience goes and then there's
pop you've heard pop pop that's like the
Midwest okay Ohio and then there's coke
yeah yeah like coke nothing can I get a
coke yeah I had to do this when I was
going to college I had to they wanted us
to get the words for what okay what do
you call if you get an ice cream cone
and you get little flavored tiny bits
all over it what do you call those
little flavored bits Oh sprinkles
okay sprinkles that's that's one of the
standards there's a there's some people
that call him jimmies
okay okay my wife's ring ones okay and I
and so I did this to her so we had that
we had a bunch of words that were broken
out that people call different things
like soda pop look what do you call this
what'd he call that where you from what
do you call this what'd he call that I
did this with my wife and I actually
luckily recorded it because I knew it
would be interesting how did you record
it like on a tape recorder
no kidding tape recorder old-school yeah
and then I go and I so I asked my wife
you know what do you call the things
that you put on an ice cream cone that
are little different colors and they're
little tiny bits of sugary candy what
would you call this and she without
missing a beat she goes hundreds and
thousands holdups and thousands as I
started laughing kind of a mouthful
hundreds and thousands yeah yeah there's
no sure and then I said because okay
what do you call ham mayonnaise lettuce
on a long bun that's what do you call
that
yeah the sandwich is that me there's no
specific but I get it I don't know ghee
okay but I don't know like a sub
sandwich
okay sub we used to call the grinder
yeah a New England grind to get it I
want to get a grinder but my my wife
calls it a bap a bap bap ham bap and
this it's like I said what do you call
that thing and she's like oh it's about
Pam bap cheese that was that just a long
sandwich like yes I look at the Subway
sandwich yes sub Club so at some point
people are just gonna say Molk
and that's gonna have a meaning yeah
beyond just what we have right now yeah
because people be making it everyone
should be trying to make it sure sure
it's gonna be just so kinda you know
it's gonna be it's like oh you'll have
it's gonna replace let's say it replaces
lunch like so like oh yeah I eat three
meals a day breakfast Molk and dinner
right oh yeah hey they're gonna come
over from all Claytor on yeah right hey
guys coming over tonight you have some
milk and watch the game do have some
olks yeah right yeah you're gonna look
on kids elementary school schedule and
be like boom you know recess and then
you know the 11:30 multiple history you
know that's where it's going the horns
gonna sound mulk break right yeah yeah
ohana let's go get some milk for some
bits pow Hana yeah yeah that's what I
said a lot of times on the my part of
the island we called it a little bit I
have the New England how I all right so
that's Moke okay
boom yeah mope does it again get your
hands on some of that you're good
yeah Potter
and I didn't analyze it means finish
work means when you're done work here
paho I know exactly what it is
come on this is for the people maybe oh
yeah but hey if you say pal PA you yeah
sounds like Pio Pio w like pow pow
that means finish literal yep directions
for you're in are you pal yeah are you
finished
hey I pal yeah I am finished definitely
yep Hana means like did you do please no
you're doing it yeah if you say Hana
hope that means let's do it again you
know whatever it is or like if some
usually they say well a common place
they say it is like if a band is playing
and it's like a dope song and they
killed it
they say Hana home means like again I
remember yelling that yeah kid or if you
go you could do something fun and you
guys are done you say your goodbyes to
your friends and you say what tomorrow
Hana home means you wouldn't do that
thing tomorrow it's good ok yes unless
back to origin our company origin made
America by the way this stuff good stuff
including G's for jiu-jitsu starting to
jet see us ask me ask jock or whatever
if you if you ask me or chuckle what
Geetha get here it is on compromised not
uncompromised no exception no exception
that I can think of anyway you get an
origin key for many many reasons I'm not
gonna go into all of them but they are
made in America and they're made for
jiu-jitsu sounds weird alright like
reduce forget G it's made for jiu-jitsu
yeah not as much as the origin geet
that's the thing you have a jiu-jitsu
guy who is an expert in textiles
manufacturing some fashion I know I know
but it's part of it and he's like you
know what I'm gonna make a geek for
jiu-jitsu for doing jiu-jitsu in you
know not just hey a'gieeewwww
which is cool and you can use the Ridgid
to let's make a bunch of blanks and
whatever brands can buy them from us and
you know
just kind of the thing and we'll ship
into them in the u.s. no it's not that
Pete made jujitsu keys for jujitsu shape
for jujitsu woven for jujitsu that's
that's important part yeah so when you
put it on you do the jujitsu yeah and
when you put it in the dryer it actually
dries yeah which is even so this is
totally doing this these keys all of
them perform when you do introduce it
and when you're not Junior sir
yeah boom there it is and all made in
America did I mention that everything
even the threads are made in America
even the cotton is grown in America no
yeah most of us already know that but
I'm gonna say it again because some of
us don't necessarily know that now we do
it's pretty cool when you're putting on
Aggie and you know the people that
actually made it yeah
that's what made it yeah they're
supporting when you're sir when you know
you're supporting the economic growth of
this country yes and at the same time
you're getting the best possible GU can
get yeah I'd say that's a hundred
percent positive that's a win-win across
the way across the board and everyone's
kind of in the game together you have
that additional like additional feeling
situation that's my opinion that's my
experience anyway also rash guards these
are good rash guards by the way um while
inventing in good-good rash guards is
that just a matter of opinion
okay or do you mean calm look at the
rash guards you'll like one get one of
those boom also the immersion camp
jiu-jitsu immersion camp one of the best
ways to learn anything including but not
limited to jiu-jitsu is to immerse
yourself in it so how many immersing
yourself in jiu-jitsu
you can't on August 26 two sessions you
can go from the 26 27 28 29 now and then
the second session the 30th through the
second right September 2nd or you can do
it all either way myself and you just do
Dean is going is Dean going yes so Dean
Lister is going Jacko's going I'm going
Leif's going basically babban is going
Dave Burke's going good deal Dave and
JP's going
so maybe Mike in Flynn this far as the
Echelon front dude my humor go maybe
maybe not
no I'm telling they're not so maybe not
no not not going okay gotcha I
understand now okay either way we're all
gonna be there and if the question it is
I don't have any jujitsu at all I don't
use it at all do I go to jujitsu camp
yes answers yeah Andy's going to look
okay and ebert Andy Berke hardcore for a
DCC yeah and oh yeah somebody asked if
if there's an is there a chance to go
see the factory where everything's made
yes and the answer is affirmative in the
middle of the week Wednesday in between
jujitsu sessions go to the factory but
you know get to see everything get to
meet the people that make everything
it's awesome
yes very much so that's a good little
hangout spot - last time we were there
we're kind of hanging out there for a
little yeah but yeah it's a good one
that's gonna be a good one eat some
lobster - if you like lobster I don't
know some people don't like lobster so
whatever maybe that's that's not the
draw yeah it's something boom all good
good camp camp Echo Lake layers mm-hmm
in Maine I'll see you there
also for fitness gear on it calm slash
chuckle good kettlebells on there the
best kettlebells me matter of opinion my
opinion yes hundred percent that's all
the only kettlebells I have on a kettle
bells and I think I have more or less
all of them all of them mix it with this
teeny tiny small ones in one series or
all of them all of them these are the
zombie one zombie ones well some of them
were sold out so aside from the sold out
ones yes I'll actually don't have start
with ones yet you're getting them but
here's the same thing the a/c so that's
the changes don't care if it's in the
game yeah a little bit little different
inspired for boba fett yes depends on
the workout but here's the thing here's
the thing I'm be honest like if I do
have the same weight maybe I'll get one
in one you know because I have double of
everything but wait double meaning for
total dollars
talk to Ethan one free time you know you
do the double handed situations yeah
those are dope good thing too about on
it calm
website is the information on their
health various philosophies in pursuits
of you know exercises and workout
programs like depending on what you want
to do stuff like that good information
about the products to also Sox I don't
know seems like a small deal I know but
I just got some in there dope and
they're kind of like you know how like
when you're going through the airport
right you got to take off your shoes
some of us almost you know I know I get
it some people they don't got to take
off the shoes but when you got to take
off your shoes and you kind of have your
socks one time so I was going through I
had the on it socks on I felt I don't
some because it felt dope because
they're kind of dope they look dope you
know seems a whole situation yeah Brad
get some socks and go travel report back
anyway I need concise chocolata letter
real good stuff on there improve
yourself also when you are shopping or
or when you're gonna shop for any of the
books that jackal recommends including
chocolate looks by the way extreme
ownership the updated one way don't
worry kid both of them discipline equals
freedom Field Manual best kind of feel
men or best kind of manual by the way
Field Manual then you can read in the
field anyway when you're shopping for
any of these books I gotta organized on
choco podcast calm JA clothes books are
in the front page right there kind of in
Plainview Marie designed the website by
the way but this is gonna stay the same
I have a page though choco podcast books
or ebooks from the episodes what it's
called anyway top menu click on there
they're all organized by episode authors
listed there with the title boom click
through there boom good way to support
biting get your books get your other
stuff from Amazon whenever you're
getting good way to support people don't
think that's a big deal it's a big deal
just that small little action has a big
reaction
kind of like remember dropping a piece
of sodium in water
people have been reminding me of that
analogy recently no we haven't talked
about it in a while you drop piece of
sodium and water it explodes to
small action by dropping a small little
thing big reaction tsilya
fair enough there you go revisit that
one anyway also subscribe to the podcast
if you haven't already on iTunes and
stitcher in Google Play and or wherever
else you listen a podcast a lot of
podcast apps so subscribe good way to
support also subscribe on youtube for
the video version of this podcast it's
something in what I call it important
the video version sure if you want to
know what junko looks like if you don't
know or you want to know what they look
like if you want to know what the guests
look like because that I think is gonna
peak your curiosity more so that's my
opinion anyway point there is video
version of the podcast also excerpts on
there put on there you know for you know
you want to share some lessons that
chocolate aux about with your friends
online email it to whatever Facebook
whatever and you know they're more
likely to listen to a little excerpt
then maybe a three-hour podcast on
something and sift through that one
lesson you wanted them to learn you soon
saying anyway YouTube subscribe if you
want good way to support also chocolates
door it's called jaw closed door this is
where you can get the shirts the very
shirt the jock is wearing right now you
can have that exact shirt exact shirt if
you want if that even means anything to
you but I think the shirts are cool
discipline equals freedom get after you
know you want to represent in your part
of the world in the field in the wild
that's wreaking chocolate or death on
this whim stuff on there as well and
patches hats to connects truckers and
flex it they're good they came out good
I think so going there let me know what
you think you think they're good get
something if you don't think they're
good let me know how I can improve a
week and improve collectively the Hat
situations people are very vocal we
invite them to be vocal if they think of
a product or a shirt design or something
and I encourage that
also rash guards on there good cool rash
guards 19% increase in performance what
we used to preach you know what I'm
gonna go ahead and continue preaching
that also psychological warfare I'll
tell you what this is if you don't know
it's an album with tracks of jockle on
there each track not singing he's saying
stuff and this is what he's saying if
you're having okay if you're having a
moments of weakness on your kind of
pursuit your campaign against weakness
is what we're calling it you having
trouble wake up waking up in the morning
every once in a while or you're you're
feeling you don't feel like working out
I know we know that if you don't feel
like working out you still work out
that's the deal you still work out you
know but every once in a while you
really don't feel like doing it or
you're so caught up in this other thing
and you kind of play games with your
mind you're like you know what I could
skip the workout and it's justified
literally justified because I would get
this other work done that I'm working on
right now that's another one but you
listen to this dr. Shaka will tell you
this track well one of the tracks on the
album you listen to it doc will tell you
why you shouldn't skip the workout and
guess what you won't skip the workout
100% effective psychological warfare is
what's called chuckling it's on iTunes
or Amazon or whatever you can buy it
wherever you buy it mp3s
that's where you can get it good way to
support check also you can get jock a
white tea you can get it dry in little
teabags and that's cool and now you can
also get it in a can cans of choco white
tea tastes really good and more
important gives you an 8,000 pound
deadlift which is you know not a big
deal but it's the same thing yeah so no
more of the sugar filled chemical laced
crappy energy drinks those are gone no
more those days are over
instead it's time for Doc a white tea in
a can books you mentioned him way the
warrior kid series getting kids on the
path now discipline hard work respect
the path to getting stronger smarter
faster and better and if you don't
believe me if you don't believe me
mmm-hmm check out my my social we take
out my Twitter and you'll see kids kids
working out cleaning their rooms
voluntarily studying voluntarily doing
book reports voluntarily check it out
it's awesome you can see it there get
your kids on the path and get your
neighbors kids on the path and get your
your nieces and nephews on the path also
a path of a warrior kid that's all about
hard work you can go to Irish Oaks ranch
calm and get some soap made by warrior
kid Aiden he started his own business
yeah I got some still it's good to go he
gets it from goat milk
yeah let me add so the again I said this
before it's important to understand too
it with you know how you get like did
your neighbor whatever they make their
little designer so maybe they looked it
up on YouTube about how to make it or
whatever they put their perfumes in and
they wrap it up in a nice little net
wrapping with a little ribbon on it
school I dig it I dig it but you don't
really use that so you know thanks you
know and I got a soap decorative piece
right whatever it's not that kind of so
no this is legit oh yeah yes so I didn't
even think to say that because I thought
everyone knew I guess no people get
suspect as a young kid maybe or you just
hear like old special so I don't then
depending on your experience I'm sure
people don't give you decorative soap
items no they don't regularly no okay
but the good thing about this soap from
my opinion it's all about function and
this soap will help you stay clean yes
sir the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual you can give the gift of
discipline you know if you know someone
that's like sort of maybe got a foot off
the path that's a person that's right
before you this print equals freedom
Field Manual yeah that's a person that
you go hey man it's got this book man
give it a just take a
cat yeah let's take a look at it yeah
doesn't look normal
no it looks actually pretty dull yeah
and then they read something and then
they say oh you know what gets them back
on the path if you want the audio
version of that it's this monocles
freedom field manual it's it's not on
audible it's on iTunes Amazon music
Google Play other mp3 platforms that's
where it's at
also for leadership extreme ownership is
the leadership book for the battlefield
for business and for life now the
audible version of that is available on
audible and it is me reading it and it's
Lafe Bab and reading it otherwise known
as Texas Batman cuz he talks it so if
you want to hear us read it not just
reading it but there's also sound
effects some sound effects we didn't go
overboard even though we were tempted we
had to pull the reins a little bit but I
don't know why I didn't very talked
about this very much but yeah check it
out the audible version of that book
also due September 25th the follow-on
book to extreme ownership it's called
the dichotomy leadership it's available
for pre-order right now Amazon Barnes &
Noble local bookstore if you want that
first edition version which you do then
order it now that way the the publishing
company who's lagging doesn't get it
living in the stone Age's they won't
print enough and then you won't get a
copy it'll take an extra week they got
to print more like happen with the
warrior Kid books like to happen with
the first extreme ownership like that
will happen with this political freedom
Field Manual they ran out if you
preorder it they won't run out so
preorder it and if you need support at
your business or your team we have a
tional on front it's me
Lafe Babb and JP Danelle Dave Burke our
website is Ashley L'Enfant comm and we
solve problems through leadership that's
what we do all the problems you have in
your business in your team and your
organization the problems that you have
all of them are leadership problems all
of them that's a bold statement to make
isn't it yes and it's factual
you're not gonna solve those problems
through spreadsheets you're gonna solve
those problems through leadership so let
us know if you need some help and of
course there's the muster we've done
five muster so far all of them sold out
the last one we did in DC was nuts it
was awesome
a lot of knowledge that's getting put
out a lot of intensity there's one more
muster in 2018 its mustard zero zero six
in San Francisco October 17th and 18th
it is going to sell out as well don't
get mad and you can't go because it's
sold out go and register extreme
ownership calm and also for current
military law enforcement firefighters
paramedics border patrol other first
responders we got roll call 0:01
September 21st in Dallas Texas
it's a focused one day Leadership
Training seminar and it's aimed at
people in uniform then you can also
register for that at extreme ownership
comm and until the muster in San
Francisco or the roll call or the
immersion camp in Maine if you want to
maintain contact with us you can't find
us on the interwebs echo is at Echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and to
those of you that are wearing the
uniform out there on the front lines
right now thank you for keeping evil at
bay and the vets that have already
served thank you for doing your share
and to the first responders police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics
Border Patrol thanks to all of you for
staying ready staying alert staying
strong and keeping us safe here at home
and to the families of all that serve
thank you for your sacrifice as your
loved ones serve us and to the rest of
you out there thanks for listening
thanks for supporting you actually make
this podcast possible so thank you but
but never mind all that thanks for doing
what you do every day
hey thanks for waking up early and
staying up late thanks for putting in
the hours the long hours
grinding working making things happen
standing up when the hard times come and
they come you're not alone
the hard times come to all of us and
when they do stand up grit your teeth
and get after it until next time this is
echo and Jocko out